the Joe Rogan experience if you if you
want to know about a person you know say
it's a politician or you know an actor
or comic or whoever you're writing about
the idea that you're gonna figure them
out with just a few hours of google
searching it's kind of crazy it's
absolutely clear and and the the rush is
to define someone in either very
flattering or very unflattering ways the
this that's really where most of the
energy goes where most of the stories
are either hit pieces or they're fluff
pieces that seem to be propped up by a
publicist yeah there is
I feel if though like I did this movie
that came out it was just a small indie
comedy where I was a guy who had two
separate families and they didn't know
about each other so it's like he's a
good guy no but he had two families and
it's a comedy it's set in the 90s and
you know the the reviews that didn't
like the movie that didn't surprise me
you know or the criticisms but like a
lot of the reviews were kind of there
was a tone of like how dare this white
male have to fit like they couldn't get
beyond like it wasn't like they would
insert like a social commentary onto a
platform that was not for that yeah do
you mean like it was there was there was
a portrayal of and there were great
female actor actors that played my wives
and there was some reviews there like
they under served them and it's like you
know what the movie was really about my
character and his son you know and but
like people were frustrated about story
but because of the day we live in it had
to be kind of deciphered through this
kind of social critique that is just
absurd and it wasn't here and there it
was a lot of reviews like that
well they feel like there's an
obligation to discuss that now to if
they feel like there's some sort of an
imbalance sexually like between genders
and on a television show or
intersectionality and that's if it has
something to do with race or gender or
politics or they feel like this is
something that must be discussed and one
of the things that I hear from friends
that are very frustrated is that when
they pitch shows the only pitch shows to
the network if they have a story an idea
like this is what we're trying to this
is the thing they're like okay where's
the diversity yeah it's like one of the
first questions they're like well it's
about an Irish family that lives in the
box like I don't know what to tell you
yeah you know it's this is what the
story is about like well where's the
diversity like you have to insert
diversity to meet their criteria like
you can't just have a you can have a
story as long as the person's like you
could have a story about a Haitian
family and it'd just be all about the
Haitian family no one's gonna say well
what about white guys we need to get
some white guys on the show no because
if you inserted the white guys then it's
the white savior story so you can't be
the white guys yeah I just can't wait
until we're done with all this I mean
maybe it maybe it'll be long after we're
done but and long after we're dead yeah
but when there's no more racism and this
is no longer a viable storyline and they
like no one gives a [ __ ] if you're
Chinese or India from Pakistan
legitimately don't care they're just
different varieties of people and
there's no judgment whatsoever I can't
wait for that time but until then we
just have to deal with these absurd
people that peddle in this this
narrative that you have to have you know
X amount of like I was reading something
where someone was saying that I should
run for I should moderate the
presidential debates fear me and someone
it's never gonna make them all smoke pot
before sure it's never gonna happen but
someone said why do that when you can
give it to a talented black woman like
okay I'm out we're out we're not we're
not talking about the way here's the
thing it's and I think you'd agree with
me I I do think there's an imbalance and
we do have to correct it yes and I do
think that like you know and it's great
that we have the the knowledge and the
foresight but humans we're just clumsy
no we're just clumsy you know with you
know we're just like let's just stick
this here where
when you know creativity is much more
complex than that
like even even any comedian we could
have carrot top here there's a nuance on
every joke he does like people can sit
there and be dismissive but like he's
like you know what I can't do that job
before I do this joke yeah
whereas people just think it's like no
just stick this in there stick a speech
in there but I almost feel is like when
greenbook one cuz i saw it after the
fact I was like kids you know like
there's this this belief of oh you know
you if you play a disabled person you
win and but it's much more of like that
movie winning was like oh yeah you know
it's it's you know the great crime of
America and race so it brings that up it
also deals with you know homosexuality
and like the struggle of that which is
profound I can't even contemplate it but
it's like that's why the movie won hmm
and it was also we love Italians with
America loves it
who doesn't love that America loves
Italians they love Boston and you know
that's you know that's there's certain
things that America loves so I was like
oh that's why it won I'm not saying it's
a bad movie I'm not taking video wasn't
great I'm just saying that's why one
yeah and it's weird it is a little weird
but it on the other hand one way to look
at it is that like this idea that there
can be no darkness without light right
there could be no there can be no real
appreciation of true diversity without
an understanding of racism like in to
have it around in its ugliest form makes
you appreciate the people that don't
express that that aren't racist that are
just even-keeled people that appreciate
everybody well you know there's there's
also this too is that you know I'm I
tend to lean left I'm pretty uh liberal
socially and but I and you know when
Trump was elected and like there was
women's March and all this stuff
there was this I had this thought
process of
like how do i how do i you know how can
i contribute how can i help make this
country better
which sounds grandiose which it is but
the thing is it's like I'm not changing
anyone's mind hmm I really believe that
it's like and if anything I think at my
shows it's like people are kind of like
a break from it yes do you I mean like
it's we're all thinking about it all the
time they're like all right there's a
tariff a Chinese tariff what does that
mean I don't know what that means is
that our American farmers destroyed
what's going on but like when they come
to my show they don't want me to rehash
it yes yeah no I think that's one of the
keys to your success is that you provide
a vacation yeah fun silly
well-thought-out comedic Lee brilliant
sort of vacation from but also pointing
out that humans are we're absurd we're
stupid
yes yeah we are so stupid like we just
think humans think we have it every
generation we think we have a figured
out yeah that's like the the the sure
admissible makes me concerned but you
know there were people at a time that
we're like here's how we serve the how
we solve the flu is we're gonna put
these leeches on people trust me it's
working like they they were convinced
that would work yeah